let's see though that there's just no
option of having a publicist and this is
a smaller festival and you're just
getting your toe in the water what are
some DIY you know do-it-yourself kind of
your own publicist I think the good
thing is the internet helps of this a
lot I think look at the I've done this
in the past too with some smaller
festivals is look at the look at people
who have covered in the past get the
usually you can get the press list for
the festival if you're gonna be doing it
yourself so they can tell you who's
gonna be there you know put together
your own press blast even if you have to
you know like if you you know create an
email address that says whatever co G
movie doc you know at whatever you know
create email address and and put
together just you mean I think everyone
knows what not a press release but like
a screening blast should this you know
has your poster your screening times a
little description of the movie the cast
and a contact and then you send that to
everyone on the list like that's what
your publicist is going to do first and
foremost to just create awareness and
also work with their publicity office a
lot like let them know like know what
the anecdotes of your story are like
what is the narrative behind your story
that people are gonna want to hear
obviously with this film people want to
hear how did how did it Sedaris how did
you get the rights and and that's the
story that I'll probably still tell
plenty plenty plenty of times ahead of
me but you know I know that or I know
what what is what is in your film that's
specific to press so my film has gay
elements I'm gay okay so that opens up
gay press or do you have a certain
minority that there's you know a lot of
festivals usually have like a Latino you
know the press presence and they're
looking they want to find someone who's
either you know I have my parents are
Cuban immigrants so that usually is then
a story that way so you kind of just
need to be aware of what are the what
are the strengths of your film that
might appeal to specific press and get
involved with the with the festival's
press offices and ask them what you can
do and and make yourself known I find
out what the internet that I feel like
the canvassing is less important I feel
like an even four years ago like the
getting postcards and putting them all
up around town and posters I feel like
that used to be the most important thing
to do would have Film Festival now I
don't really know at least at Sundance
I don't really almost no one did that
you know and we had like some postcards
in a couple posters but it just depends
on I feel like the program cried and
people will look things up on the
Internet
you know having a nice well maintained
Facebook page I feel is even more
important than putting up posters all
around town
someone might disagree with me on that
but lately I found that that that seems
to be more important have you ever done
your own social media I do my own social
oh yeah oh yeah definitely I you know
are you obsessive about checking Twitter
yeah I'm not mentally as good with
Twitter as I should be I've been running
the Facebook page more because I feel
like I can I should be better about
Twitter because that's obviously has a
little bit more exposure sometimes but
Facebook I get more how to create it
like I got how to integrate images more
I got how to make it look better right I
have a have a relationship with the guy
who runs satirises page so we can run
links to that and get attention that way
whereas like Twitter we don't
necessarily have that kind of like and I
also don't my own personal Twitter I
don't update that much I'm really bad
with this I should be better with
Twitter but the Facebook one I run a lot
and I I just try to make sure to keep
content on it you know at least twice a
week put something up you know even if
it's just a update or something you know
so that people don't forget about it and
keep it going but I haven't been able
with the festival is one thing and the
festival Sundays have generated a lot of
its own press but now I'm getting into a
little bit more of the DIY mode which is
like okay we have our distribution
coming up I know I have to be
responsible for a lot of awareness of
the film so I need to start getting out
there a lot more
you